question for you so some people will say
look
you know if you're really going to do
the whistleblower stuff why don't you go
after both sides because at least sasha
baron cohen will go and expose
you know maybe 10 of people he exposes
is the opposing side you know he did
something with bernie sanders his own
side
uh i think he went after bernie i don't
know he did something different i mean
there's something intense to go after
especially with the last year there's no
question about the people from the hotel
all that stuff this is
to to those who ask that question is
this a pure crusade
you have against the left or is anybody
that does
uh uh uses their power against people to
manipulate defi i i think we need to
define these things when we say side
what do we mean we say left i'm not even
sure what that means anymore because i
have the fbi working with the new york
times is that left wing
let's define reality there's only one
reality there's only one truth veritas
does 24 24 frames per second or now it
on the iphone with the high definition
it's 64. i don't know what how many
frames truth at 24 frames per second
there's only one reality there's only
one truth
our medium is to film things film people
talking and oftentimes we don't feel you
see their lips moving so that happened
it's an event
over time you'll see us do everything we
just did a video on alex stovall's
republic in arizona he's a republican
running for congress and he said one
thing in private and another thing in
public he contradicted himself and we
exposed it
and we were not condemned by the right
in fact
my that reaction that story it seemed
like
[Music]
people on the right appreciated it even
more because they didn't want people on
their side uh when i say right
republican party if that's even right
wing so i'm not sure what i what we
there he is uh uh project veritas action
exposes flip-flopping arizona
congressional candidate this was a guy
who said uh privately
that there wasn't enough fraud over to
the election and publicly that there was
so he so i'm not saying he was wrong by
saying privately what he said it was the
fact that he contradicted himself but
that that would still be seen as one
side that's what i would
i mean if he's against uh
fraud for election
and then he says it that is a
that is against the the idea of many
people on the right
however many you want to say that
thought the election was a fraud so for
him to flip that i don't necessarily
think i put him as a
person who would essentially be
on the right to defend some of the
philosophies you got to keep in mind
this is a show where we defend
capitalism this is a show about you know
a person who escaped iran to go to
germany i lived at a refugee camp i'm a
kid who grew up in a communist family in
an imperialist family mother's side they
were all communists that said we're
imperialists but it's it's more it's
more strong to say listen here's what
we're doing we're
covering up the guys on the opposite
side i'm not a comedian i'm not sasha
baron cohen here's what we're doing this
is what we stand for this is where we're
going uh but at the same time there is a
big audience out there that will say you
target mainly once and and you know what
they're going to say that until they
stop saying it because we have people
coming to us now like like i say the
darpa the the marine corps major who
wrote which by the way there's nothing
wrong with that i mean you're going
against if you're going up against the
government that's
what you stand for well here's two two
quick responses here's the irony of them
saying i go off to the left by exposing
cnn there's an admission there are you
saying that cnn is left are you saying
the new york times is left is the fbi
left is our federal bureau of
investigation left are our
pharmaceutical companies left is this
guy left so at a certain point that
argument is it's over what's going to
happen there's an asymptote on the on to
or a mathematical analogy that asymptote
will approach
you know zero and and people are going
to come to us they can't go anywhere
else
cnn
the the network cnn gives a deliberate
false impression daily they they say the
two plus two equals five we got a guy at
cnn saying
quote where propaganda the control room
director he said we're propaganda and
he's talking about the death numbers on
the screen his name was chester charlie
chester c-h-e-s-t-e-r
this is probably one of the biggest
investigations we ever did i was most
proud of this one and he goes
why can't it be higher we need the
deaths to be higher more people from
kova need to die so we have higher death
numbers higher death this is what this
guy is saying i didn't say it he's
saying it you can see his lips moving
he's being secretly recorded at a bar
so these networks there it is quote if
it wasn't for cnn i don't know trump
would have gotten voted out now i did
not entrap him
we did not tell him to say these things
we asked questions
i did not ask leading questions
our undercover people said tell us about
what your network is like we're
propaganda we get trump out so if that's
my question is a rhetorical one
why won't the people at cnn say that
publicly
say what say the fact
if it wasn't for cnn trump wouldn't have
gotten voted out quote where propaganda
quote why won't the death numbers be
higher there's nothing by the way i'm
not making a moral judgment about that
right and i won't
that's something about me that's
different than all the other journalists
you see on tv
i'm not making my only judgment is this
my only rule is this
don't say something privately
if you are a powerful man like that that
you're not willing to say publicly okay
so we both know that happens in your
organization that happens in our
organization that happens in every media
every sports team every business every
company
there's going to be certain things
you're going to talk about
aspirational behind closed doors where
for example tom brady every time they
interview him after he wins again this
is what tom brady will say
you know we have to respect those guys
on the other side we have tremendous
respect for the coaches that's right you
know
jimmy g and the kicker for san francisco
what's the kicker's name
do you know what i'm talking about the
kickers big goal yeah
you know we respect the guys on the
other side the green bay packers have a
world-class organization and then you
see the clip that they recorded on [ __ ]
the backers yeah did you see that one
part so listen who doesn't do it i think
everybody does it partly on the other
side because
to compete at that level especially
media you have an enemy cnn's enemy is
fox fox's enemy is mainstream media
msnbc has an enemy everybody's got an
enemy and quite frankly everybody's
mainstream media's enemy right now is
joe rogan who is kicking everyone's ass
so there is an enemy in every place so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]